me just start off yeah okay well good
afternoon and welcome to this August
setting what a beautiful spot I guess
it's appropriate that we're considering
the future of Medicare in a room that
looks like it's been around for several
hundred years and I just wanted to I'm
that's the last thing I'm going to say
about Medicare in my introduction I'm
James Madison famously said that no man
is allowed to be a judge in his own
cause and since I'm actually as part of
the scrum I'm not going to get it
advanced any of my comment except to say
that they're going to be very
well-considered at thoughtful and and
you should really like them so I want to
thank Zakk Cooper who's a professor in
the School of Public Health an economist
because he's really the one who set this
up and he was able to set it up because
of the amazing staff that we have at the
institution for Social Policy Studies
and Pam Lamonica Pam green Laurie
hirschmann Tori Bilski these amazing
staff members were what made really made
this event possible and I would only say
one other thing is it I guess I'm on
your left that having set this up Zach
managed to position the panel so that I
would be the most liberal commentator
which is a position I don't always find
myself in there actually are people who
quite a lot of people who criticize me
for for not for example during the last
health care reform debate calling for
single-payer national health insurance
so this time i guess i'm going to i'm
going to i'm going to play the type and
and be and be a stalwart defender of
medicare in ways that all discuss oh
I've already broken my role twice so I'm
going to leave Sarah to do the intro but
I really want to thank everyone for
participating in and I just want in this
I just want to say a few words about the
institution for social and policy
studies it was it is it is as old as
Medicare well not quite it was create
1968 Medicare was a 65 of course and
when it was created it was in this burst
of enthusiasm for the Social Sciences in
fact i think the the president of Yale
at the time said that it would bring an
explosion of the social sciences to bear
on pressing real-world problems which
doesn't I don't know sound all that
exciting to those in the social sciences
if they're exploding but it turned out
that there wasn't a major advances that
occurred in the social sciences at that
time and in later years and I think it's
very heartening to have this enthusiasm
about what the social sciences can do to
illuminate the kinds of issues we
grapple with every day and that's really
what is PS is seeking to do I've been
head of the institution since july two
thousand eleven and in that time I've
really focused around three pillars
advancing the high-level social science
research that we do in political science
sociology economics psychology and and
then trying to do more to actually bring
that research to bear on important paulo
domestic policy questions and one aspect
of our work that i really want to
emphasize is that we're also trying to
develop the next generation of leaders
in public policy and public policy
research and we have a number of
programs underway that engage graduate
students and undergraduates and the
events like these that are to bring
together a broad cross-section of the
university community really express that
that larger mission the last thing I'll
say is that with Zach at the helm I'm
launching a healthcare initiative at
ISPs which will include him and this
amazing group of Health Policy scholars
that Yale has developed over the last
ten years or so including a big luck in
the law school Amanda Kowalski and
economics Jodie Sindelar at the School
of Public Health Fiona Scott Martin at
the School of Management Betsy Bradley
who is starting a new global health
program Harlan krumholtz at the Medical
School I could go on but the point is we
have a lot of the top health policy
experts in the in the country indeed in
the world and we're trying to bring them
under isps is umbrella to really think
together and we're
try to develop effective effective
research and strong policy ideas all is
all of which is to say I really hope
that if you're interested in these
topics you get involved with ISPs our
website is psi led you just redesigned
is a really good portal for all the work
we're doing so thank you and thanks for
coming for this event great well thank
you everyone for being here my name is
Sarah Kliff I'm a health policy reporter
at The Washington Post and very excited
to be here with this great group of
people to talk about one of my favorite
subjects Medicare which you know as a
health policy reporter right now it's a
really exciting time to be looking at
this program definitely a challenging
time but one when we're talking about a
lot of different ways you know this
program is going to develop and there
could be very big changes on the horizon
so I'd love to start you don't let my
panelists introduce themselves a little
bit and I guess I'd also love to hear
everyone's thoughts as we're getting
started on this discussion of what the
what you see is the main challenge on
Medicare is it spending is its structure
of the program but kind of what is the
big challenge when you think about
Medicare policy I guess I'll start with
you is a sure so thanks and thanks
everyone for for coming so I guess the
question for me is do we have a Medicare
problem or health care spending problem
yeah one things we seem to last 45 years
is that health care spending is going
faster than the rest of the economy and
the byproduct of that is that the
Medicare program is becoming much more
expensive the reason I think Medicare is
such an issue today is we cover 50
million elderly Americans right now if
we look out in 40 years that numbers
going up to that 90 million and so you
got more people who are going to need to
be covered yet prices or the cost of
introducing Medicare going up and then
by virtue of this age and you've got a
smaller base who's going to pay for it
and the question is where do we want our
investments to go okay do we want a
large or share government spending right
now it's a sixth of what the government
spends projected to go to
do we want that to be the case do we
want all the money going to this single
program that's going to occupy a larger
share over time or do we want to see it
start transitioning to make the
investments we probably need to make an
infrastructure in early childhood
education and in research and the
question I think fundamentally is how do
we how do we do that and I think our
politics right now you know if you ask
voters what they want they want access
to basically they want everything and
don't want to pay for anybody else to
have it and so I think our politicians
are responding to it and the question is
how do we introduce the types of changes
either through a private road or
probably distancing Medicare from the
day-to-day machinery of government that
allows us to make the types of changes
we need to make to make this program
sustainable I'm David Brooks from the
New York Times I should say that when I
was invited to this I was promised I
would be taking part in a roundtable
discussion I thought I said I could hide
my entrance I was only given a
semicircle so I'm a little more exposed
than I hope to be but I know the least
about the policy of anybody up here so
my interests are in the politics of it
and in making sure we have less of it
and so you know I've read a zillion
different versions of the following
statistic that the average Medicare
recipient couple days you reap vastly
different numbers but the ratios are
usually similar they may pay a hundred
forty five thousand dollars over the
course of their career into the system
and take out 345,000 that's sort of one
ratio effort of many different versions
but the basic truth I think seems to be
people pay a lot less than they take out
and that's basically unsustainable and
so my entire interest in the Medicare
issue is how do we get less of it and so
entitlements will used to be a small
share of income of the federal
government now they're a medium share or
medium/large by 2022 I think they'll
basically consume all of total federal
revenue and so that's simply
unsustainable and the effect which is
not future but which is current is the
squeeze on entitlement programs I mean
on discretionary
programs and so the Barack Obama
attacked Paul Ryan rightly I think for
having an unconscionably low level of
discretionary spending so historically
discretionary spending has covered
around three or four percent of GDP and
domestic discretionary is all this stuff
education welfare infrastructure it's
usually been about three or four and
Obama noted in the Ryan budget it gets
down to about one point seven percent of
GDP which i think is unsustainably low
if you go to the President's budget in
the OMB numbers his budget gets down
within seven years to one point eight
percent of GDP so the Obama budget is
the Ryan budget and you have to do that
because of the way Medicare is expanding
and eating up everything else so to me
the government has become a giant
machine for taking money from struggling
young families and giving it to a flu
and elderly people and I basically want
to turn that around and I don't really
care how if it's single pair would do it
or a big part of a big single-payer
system basically I'd accept that I
basically by the deal that that you
can't just that the fundamental problem
is that is in the incentives at the base
of the fee-for-service system incentives
and so somehow we have to look and
change those incentives and so that's my
basic interest and for anybody who's a
current recipient of Medicare I think if
you're above a certain income level you
should pay less pay more and get less
and if you don't like it I'm going to
try to outrun you we have an exit right
over I could quit there and say I agree
with David I'm supposed to get more than
the weeds I guess so anyway i'm tom
scully and i'm a partner in a private
equity firm in New York but my role here
I was President Bush 41 s healthcare
staffer in the White House for four
years the most of stuff for George Bush
one and then I came back for George Bush
43 and ran was then called hick fuh I
change the name to CMS when I was there
the first week so I ran CMS for about
three and a half years my primary job
there was designing and pushing through
Medicare Part D which was very
controversial at the time and one thing
I would knows I think David's right
about the politics at the time I was a
horrible
line took horrible person report view
Medicare Part D and now it's not
controversial law so one of the worst
things about the health care politics is
that you know I was not I didn't support
everything President Obama did I
probably would have spent a lot less but
the structure the Obama plan is
virtually identical the structure of the
George Bush one plan that I wrote in
1992 with [ __ ] are men who you may
have noticed since passed away
structurally it's the same things but
President Obama is trying to is right
whether you should do it at the time of
a ten percent of GDP deficit and whether
you should do it with the massive amount
of spending we're taking on in one day
next January first is another issue but
my point is it's like Pavlov's Bell
Democratic administration proposes
something in a Republican beats the hell
out and says they're wrong without
looking at substance and I'm Part D I
can promise you if you go back and look
at it every Democrat beat us up because
it was George Bush's idea so it must be
terrible now it's very hard to find a
Democrat that like Medicare Part D and
it's the program's a huge success so
sadly the politics rarely as I can do
with the substance which is unfortunate
but I think with the areolar she comes
down with Medicare is private versus
public so if you really look at it I
personally believe I love Medicare it's
a great program why do seniors love it
it's a twelve thousand dollar benefit on
average that a senior pace 1,200 bucks
for so what's not to love and ninety
percent subsidized benefit especially if
you're rich and you're living in Naples
Florida playing golf and fundamentally
the issues how do you deliver services
appropriately and if you look at the
models and I think work the federal
employee health benefits plan I was a
federal employee for 16 years eight
million federal employees get their
plans get their health care by buying it
through a very competitive
well-regulated set of private plans the
federal employer benefits plans every
federal employee looks Medicare Part D
is a totally private negotiated system
run by private contractors the
government's not involved at all it's
worked pretty well funtime a problem
with Medicare is its single-payer if you
like single-payer the government I love
a mild staff fixes prices every doctor
in New Haven every hospital in New Haven
gets paid the same thing in the history
of mankind and the history of every
economy in the world price fixing has
never worked if you fix prices and you
pay every doctrine every hospital the
same thing what do you get volume
explosions I mean it's you know one plus
one equals two and the phone no problem
Medicare is the government fixes prices
so fundamentally if you want to make the
system work better at some point
which I believe you need to get to the
point we have people buying
well-regulated private Blue Cross or
retina we're united healthcare plans
instead of having the government fixed
prices you know the government doesn't
fix prices for food and it doesn't fix
prices for public housing you know the
two things the government needs to
provide and the economics the problem
Medicare is the government has a
single-payer and it see behavioral it's
a wonderful problem but a behavioral
disaster so when I went to the CMS in
2001 we had three percent of people in
private health plans and now its twenty
eight and a half percent almost nobody's
noticed that the twenty-five percent of
seniors this year will be in a private
health plan they get better services
they get more coverage and lower costs
and you know well regulated competition
works so I think part these an example
that the film employer benefits system
is an example but and I think part of
the Medicare Advantage when will run is
an example that so when you really look
at the fundamental problem of Medicare
Medicare is a critical program it's not
going to go away you might have to make
it work better you have to at least have
some semblance of price and quality
competition and I think that's really
the key issue that too many people talk
past well I guess having set this up
this way Zach you're going to make me
play to type because I think it's really
important to start with two critical
points one is the enormous value of
Medicare as a program and and one way to
understand that is to think about why
the health care market is not like the
market for food or house and quiet is
that before Medicare existed was so hard
for seniors to get affordable health
insurance and the primary reason is as
most of you probably know is that a very
small portion of people account for most
costs so and we're not talking here
about doing away with Medicare we're
talking about having this this set of
options that is being discussed is about
having a basic commitment but having
some kind of competitive mechanism for
among plans but i just want to remind
people that the reason why medicare
exists at all is that there's a fund
there are fundamental problems in the
health care market that medicare had was
there to address namely that it was
almost impossible for our seniors to get
affordable health insurance
before the program existed and
especially as plans got more and more
sophisticated they're certainly
sophisticated now at trying to weed out
high cost patients now a couple quick
points one is that Medicare's costs
right now are growing more slowly than
any other part of the health system and
that's not a new development it's
costume in growing more slowly than
private health insurance costs by
roughly appoint a year since the 1970s
more there's a larger difference in
recent years right now we're talking
about Medicare costs gross there is
essentially zero and that while it's
hard to know how much that's due to some
of the reforms that are being pursued
with in Medicare I think it's worth
noting that this is not a new
development this general system-wide
control of costs that we're seeing right
now or at least slow down and cost is it
is even more accelerated with in
Medicare the second thing I would say is
and I think this is very important to
understand is that the private plans
within Medicare which I support and I've
argued for a similar system for the non
elderly population that is a system
where there are private plans but also a
public option the Medicare public option
if you will competing with private plans
is has consistently lost money because
of the private plans and the reason
being that they have selected healthier
patients and the reason being is well
because there's been actual subsidies
for the plans that are thankfully being
ratcheted down although partially offset
by some some quality subset of payments
the last point I would want to make here
is that if the concern is about Medicare
becoming smaller that that isn't a very
strong argument as Zach was suggesting
at the outset is question for much more
aggressive attempts to control costs
both within Medicare and beyond and I am
a health care deficit Hawk if you will
I've called for an enforceable budget
for Medicare spending I believe that the
mechanisms and Medicare users of control
cost is Steve Brill and this very
informative Time magazine article talks
about where Medicare is paying much less
for individual services and individual
Goods than is than our private insurance
plans that there should be a move to try
to do that kind of serious efforts to
control costs at a broader level than
just
individual fees and prices but but my
point would be that and I believe in the
Independent Payment Advisory Board which
is basically independent in substantial
respects from political control with a
mandate to control costs so one can be
strongly supportive of reducing Medicare
size while not believing that the right
solution is to shift more costs onto
seniors or to rely more on private plans
and one factor that we should keep in
mind when we talk about very wealthy
Medicare beneficiaries is it in 2012 and
I won't try to show you this figure I
will try to but you won't be able to see
it five percent of Medicare
beneficiaries that incomes above eighty
eight thousand dollars a year fifty
percent had incomes below twenty two
thousand dollars a year twenty-five
percent of incomes below 14 thousand
dollars a year it is a wonderful thing
that the elderly are no longer the most
disadvantaged segments of our society
but we shouldn't pretend that that we're
talking that the bulk of Medicare
spending is going to really ask level
criminal oh yeah I mean I think that's I
mean the question is what's this is not
some lunch every day by the way yeah
exactly I mean it's question is what's
what's the precedent for the private
sector you know and if we look outside
of Medicare there really is the prices
that are rising for private insurers in
the president hospitals are charging
that are driving up health care spending
so if we look outside the elderly
population it's precisely the sort of
consolidation the hospital industry and
the the weakening of these private
insurers that's feeling taken to it take
prices down like the second issues if we
look at who introduced regulated prices
it wasn't Democrats it was Ronald Reagan
you know introduced the price fixing and
I think the challenge is there's just
not a whole lot of evidence you know
Jacob talked about yeah the Medicare
Advantage program like Part D the other
challenge with it is pharmaceutical
spending so it was part of what happens
with Medicare Part dates come in under
budget you know and that's that's been
one of the largest oregon's made for it
it came in under budget essentially
because pharmaceutical spending slowed
down in the two thousand law I didn't
get slowed down he was magic we know but
it slowed down for the Lincoln things
slow down slow down for one reason was
that
the rally which drives me crazy the
Democrats want to close the doughnut
hole which may be the dumbest policy in
history of the world I spent years
design thing okay the donut hole is to
not there there are 15 million seniors
that have no co-payments and no
deductibles for you as you go up an
income stream you have welcomed subsidy
people there another seven right know
that have significant subsidies the
reason the spending is dropped is
because there's a significant cost share
and seniors are smart and a January
second when they realize that they're
not rich they're gonna donut hole they
switch to generics but then while Eric's
one twenty-five percent to eighty
percent but switch to generics was all
of it and it was designed to be their
way so when you go out and tell us about
of not a non poor senior by the way
we're gonna close the doughnut hole by
collecting taxes and the guy digging
ditches out front to subsidize your
drugs they're gonna say well maybe I'll
just keep taking lipitor else's on
patents to switch into a generic the
reason the kinder price was 100% the
donor hole and the reason was designed
that way was to drive non for seniors in
the making rational choices to get away
from the umber and drugs and go to
generics it wasn't my accent but you
wouldn't expect then the you know the
the share under 65 to mirror the share
over 65 so a Medicare was somehow doing
something totally differently the rate
of spending growth a pharmaceutical care
yeah for those in under six fighting
those overseas so it would look very
very different and what they look is
almost identical and some of that's
because more generic more drugs were
going on too generic yeah which explains
a lot of the increase in generic
prescribing some was awake the world and
look at how the PBM business which is
what the trustees say the reduced
estimates reflect the higher market
penetration of generic drugs and decline
in the number of new drug products are
expected to reach the market during this
period and it should be noted that the
35 there's that private drug spending
came in thirty five percent under
expectations whereas Medicare was
forty-one percent under projections but
the difference is because if you were
than expected people signed up well yeah
I would note I was a trustee for years I
would note the chief actuary with that
report estimated that part do you'd be
twice what it cost today and he was
totally wrong I had many public flights
of them he was he was wrong I love him
he's a great guy he was fundamentally
wrong behaviorally what's driven the
change is the change to generics and
also the fact that the PBM business
which is help you buy pharmaceuticals
caremark and med go in those folks used
to be a pass-through business most
business understand one of the things
that have the party is most large
employers started realizing wow these
guys
care about our costs are worried about
rebates and drug companies that have
changed the behavior I mean so I'm super
sympathy in a sympathetic to competition
most my research is on the effective
competition on raising prices so so
consolidation increases the price the
challenge that we look globally there's
just no precedent for it in the prices
in the US are vastly higher than they
are in any other country we're also the
only ones who will out price competition
for everything I mean sorry for drugs
attire but your price competition is
that when you look at the market she
died and i agree with you by the way and
I trust enforcement is probably the most
important thing solid ation of hospitals
which is a disgrace around the country
consolidates of insurance plans as a
signal is a significant problem in a
healthy market the doctors the hospital
insurance company should all have
relative balance of power and not like
each other very much that's a good thing
and there's way too much of that going
on but when you look at competition in
the marketplace for Medicare eighteen
percent of the people in country are
seniors fifty percent of consumption and
the government fixes prices another
twenty five percents Medicaid so when
you say we allow price competition it's
kicked the ball and dragged the
government the vast bulk of the market
is price fixed by the federal government
you got in a major market we have huge
insurance consolidation and the biggest
insurance carol of seven eight nine
percent of the market a really strong
blue cross plane why because the
government dominates the market and the
insurers are minor players well if you
look at say c sections which most
medicare beneficiaries aren't having the
average the average price for a
c-section in the next most expensive
nation is australia where it is ten
thousand dollars its fifteen thousand
united states it is and let's just throw
in a couple France six thousand dollars
New Zealand four thousand seven hundred
dollars the Switzerland which is a
country that has a system that is it's
similar in some respects to what the
Affordable Care Act is seeking to
achieve is around five thousand dollars
so I mean we are time you know someone
sums it up I think there's a lot going
on but but the price levels in the US
are much higher than in other countries
but I'll bet you if you look at you look
at this chart they've got a lot worse
since nineteen sixty-five oh yeah this
is just the yeah 2012 and the reason
since nineteen sixty-five is god bless
the medicare program you getting the
mechanics of the medicare program you
get any teaching hospital the country a
nice to run a big Hospital Association
you go to the poorest town in the
country they got a brand new hospital of
two new wings and what's it built with
Medicare money
is everyone who gets massive subsidies
from medicare ime gme this portion share
payments it's behind me I don't email
hospital they can tell you I'm the board
of the Dartmouth Medical Center I love
it we got a brand new hospital building
the wings every week I mean every
hospital the country is its Medicare
money so the way I started was saying to
have a Medicare problem or a health care
problem and your argument is that the
Medicare problem is what's exacerbating
this okay April it's created the
Medicare the Medicare problems
creatively health care behavioral
problem and it's making it worse and
it's very very very political it's not
going to get better without people
understanding the mechanics and the
details do we do we have agreement maybe
for Jacob on on the basic the doughnut
hole skin in the game if I can combine
two ugly metaphors that it that the
consumer consciousness on the part of
the recipients is a key part of the
solution do you agree with anything I
agree with it insofar as there should be
cost-sharing particularly there should
be cost-sharing and there is quite a lot
of customer already a Medicare in fact
one thing I would say and I think we
might all agree on this unification of
Part A and Part B and creating some
catastrophic coverage would be a really
important reform that left and right
should agree on however I will note and
this comes out of the work of Jonathan
Gruber that they're there are that cost
sharing is not particularly effective
for the for the highest cost cases and
those often also vote and and so what
you want to be careful with clustering
is in a basically a tax on the sick and
that and that is a real fear
particularly what sort of so-called
consumer-directed health plans Oh since
healthier people tend to select into
them that's not been a big problem but
we're that to be more than norm well if
you went back to the ranch sorry just
really quickly if you go to the r and
health insurance experiment of the 1970s
which is sort of considered the gold
standard for thinking about cost sharing
they found two things right they found
that cost sharing seemed to be pretty
effective particularly in reducing
hospital care but it was not very the
individuals were not very good at
distinguish between necessary and
unnecessary care and it wasn't a long
enough experience to know what the real
health effects would be so cost sharing
it strikes me it can be an important
component but to think that that's going
to really be what's going to create
substantial sustained reduction in cost
over time especially when five percent
of the patients are accounting for half
the cost that's that is the number razor
it just is it seems unrealistic
ten percent of Medicare beneficiaries
were responsible for fifty-seven percent
of the spending in the program but not
that there's a very very tiny group who
were essentially driving costs up and I
think the question is how do we address
the spending of that very very small
portion publicly there's a lot of issues
that you're including hospice care right
you know when you look at cost sharing
there is no cost sharing its Medigap
well yes but opposed Medigap his garbage
insurance Medigap but most seniors I'll
bet peel in this audience say don't
understand the fact it's not Medicare
they say well I have Medicare and as
these ridiculous thousand-dollar beloved
Anala doubles for hospital care and
whatever for 116 126 for physician care
but blue I really pay it no I pay Blue
Cross a Connecticut 400 bucks a month on
top of my Medigap so I do drivers
insurance and it has sixty-five percent
medical loss ratio is it has nothing to
do with Medicare program but people are
insulated from the cost share so they're
totally insensitive to it so when they
go to the hospital ago the doctor most
of them don't care because that there is
no cost-sharing so the fact that you
know you could changing the deductibles
if you allow people to buy Medigap
doesn't matter defeats the purpose
what's it to Jacob would you allow us to
kick Medigap out the window yes okay
absolutely so we've but I reached
consent we definitely it would it would
have to be done with not just serious
attention to income related mission in
qiyam related cost sharing but also
condition related cost sharing and
Gruber has a really nice proposal for
this that I would recommend looking at
so we've combined a and B and then we've
kicked out Medigap yeah so and and the
you know the one thing I would note is
your only 100 senators and 435 miles per
hr a man you ever you get some big sway
there this is really would require
because I think people don't understand
just quite how high out-of-pocket
spending is by the elderly on health
care now part of this is is is long-term
care spending which is not covered by
Medicare even though people believe it
is but but part of it is just that that
Medicare actually has some really
strange coverage rules that mean that
cost cost sharing can be very high so
the old 120 hospital days rule right
which may have made sense in 1965 but
doesn't today so I mean one thing the
ipad i think or an independent
organization could be authorized to do
in the future
would be to think about benefits changes
that wouldn't reduce overall benefits
you might say to use technical terms the
actuarial value of benefits but could
have authority to change the benefit
structures in ways that would reduce
that that would make more harmonious the
treatment of different services what do
you do you are you comfortable with I
hub this is eric technical field no i
mean because i think it's it's a
question should 15 people be able to
make i think it'd be the most effective
thing but are we comfortable with that
right so well i'm a Burkean so I I
generally have limited faith that 15
extremely smart people sitting in
Washington will be able to master some
large percent of the gdp and I have
double my doubts when I see how Congress
structured I've had which as I
understand it has been limited and mask
you laid and they didn't want to give
away total control for legitimate
Democratic reasons and then the third
thing I'll say is I used to believe in
in I'm now blanking on the name the base
closing Commission I forgot anyway for a
clothes rack right right so I used to
believe in that solution to all our
fiscal problems let's just give it to
some Commission yeah and I no longer
believe that because this is an
elemental feature of our social contract
and you just can't do it and
undemocratic means and if you speak to
people who've been around the head of
memorable lunch with dick garment which
I'll talk a little about later maybe but
he and others who are in the Senate and
been around a long time Alice Rivlin
said Commission's like this only work
when they are a mask for legislators who
secretly already want to do something
and just need a cover for and so when
you get legislators rigging a commission
then the Commission can work if you ask
a commission to do something legislators
are not politically brave or foolish
enough to do it will fall apart mmm yeah
i agree but what I was one of darwin's
deputies with but you know the issues of
that ipad will never happen number one
for political reasons is david's ang
definite i have not been I've quietly
been a supporter for one reason senator
Rockefeller whose idea was an old trend
and I spent a lot of time passing our
brbs with him back in 1989 and his view
as a legislator is when you're sitting
around trying to run the Medicare
from the Ways and Means Committee in the
House and the Senate skin the Senate and
you can't make decisions you watched 20
years of inaction you throw up your arms
and say at least I'll give it to a panel
of experts who have the guts to do
something from that point of view I
don't disagree with them and I think
from his level of frustration I think
I've had may be fine if you get to that
point the federal issue is should the
government fixing prices at all I mean I
would say if you're going to be stuck
fixing prices I'm happy to give it to 15
experts a little better job than
Congress who shouldn't be in micro
managing these things but fundamentally
should somebody be out there evaluating
the relative value of an internist and
you know a guy gets out of Yale med
schools 29 or let's say the University
of Western Guatemala med school 29 and
he gets paid the same thing to practice
medicine in New Haven as the guys the
demon of med school that doesn't have
any place else so when you're out there
having the government set relative
values you fundamentally issue is should
the government be fixed on those prices
if you're going to I guess I'd rather 15
experts doing a bunch of meatheads in
Congress I wanted it I did actually I've
written on the subject a little bit i
wrote a piece am for the post called who
wants to be a death panelist kind of
yeah raising the issue you raised of
them it's one of probably the most
unenviable jobs in Washington to be the
one who says no you're going to get paid
less I wanted to ask you although about
some of the other reforms in the health
care law because you know we often talk
about the affordable care act as an
insurance expansion about half of the
law is related to changing how Medicare
gets paid and them some of the ones that
come to mind for me are accountable care
organizations where a health care system
gets a fixed amount to cover a specific
patient and you know if they can cover
in that budget that's great they get to
keep some profit if not they're
essentially on the hook and it carries
another one that I that has been getting
a lot of attention from hospitals are
penalties for readmissions for
preventable readmissions am I think
there's actually a new york times
article about this a few days ago about
you know some Hospital saying it's
really hard for us to manage people
scare outside the hospital I'm curious
if everyone will have thoughts on this
just judging from how this panel is
going so far but if anyone wants to talk
a little bit about the Affordable Care
Act and how you see that you know
whether that's going to help solve our
Medicare cost problem or you know but
we'll make any sort
change well I'll just say very briefly
that I think that we should start with
the basic principle that there are two
major sources of Medicare cost growth
right over time one is that there are
more people enrolling in the program and
because Medicare costs have been growing
so slowly and in fact I think was 140
billion dollars is just shaved off the
projected growth because of that most of
the coast growth right now is being
driven by increasing enrollment in the
program and I think we should think
differently about those two sources of
cost increase to think that we could so
reduce the perc you know actually bring
down say or stop entirely the growth in
per capita spending would would be
really a mistake and we and and and so
when we're thinking about a lot of these
plans and proposals on the table one of
the really important questions is like
what is the achievable rate of growth
and what's interesting is that there's
actually a lot of agreement now across
the ideological spectrum that you need
to have some rate of growth that is you
know close to the growth of our economy
but slightly higher right whether it's
the international average which was
around a half percent more whether its
current levels you know which PD which
is 0 point four percent more a per
capita and you know age-adjusted growth
of because as people get older they
spend more and I think that's really
important because what's going to
deliver that kind of growth if you look
at the rest of the world what is
delivered the slower growth that we've
seen than we see in the United States is
countervailing power on the part of
insurance institutions which are either
the state or sickness funds which are
basically mutual insurance institutions
that have state sanctioned it's it's
highly regulatory and it works
regardless of what the unit is because
there it's very hard to control the cot
the the pressure from increasingly
consolidated US private providers is to
get higher prices as a real article
suggests is very very strong and you
need to have that kind of railing power
so most of the reforms that are being
pursued I think through Medicare makes
sense as a way of trying out new
techniques but my own view is that
ultimately it's going to come from
saying we're not going to let medic
spending grow faster than a certain
amount and we're going to give
authorities pretty substantial power to
create that kind of countervailing power
to support something like a per capita
cap on spending her yes I have proposed
that however I would separate that from
ideas I think it's quite important to
separate that from plans that have some
kind of fixed voucher for for coverage
in the other Medicare traditional
Medicare coverage or private plans for
reasons we can go into later but I think
that if if there isn't that that
structural feature there isn't the
incentives to basically shift costs on
the seniors right that you have real
protections that cost savings are going
to come through actual reduction in cost
through variety of means rather than
through more costs being shifted on to
seniors then I would be supportive of it
well you know we talking past each other
in the policy and these things again so
if you look at what President Obama's
health plan does I have a problem with
the level of subsidies I'm probably
adding 20 million new Medicaid
beneficiaries in January first another
eighteen million people in exchanges and
the speed which is happening but what
did President Obama do in the formal
care act he bought private insurance for
all these uninsured Americans with
vouchers exactly what the Ryan wants to
do for Medicare he said let's go out and
set exchanges up let's buy private
insurance and let subsidized build based
on their income with a transfer payment
through vulnerable tax credits exactly
the way Medicare ryan's medicare thing
would work for the measurement issues if
you look at the the best reform plan out
there can't pass the best policy out
there and i've been saying this for 10
years senator wyden a liberal democrat
from oregon who says let's get rid of
medicaid let's get rid of Medicare let's
put everybody in one big exchange like
the president wouldn't buy them all a
basic health plan based on their age and
their income and have them subsidized so
we have one system that functions
together and we have essentially these
community whether they're for profit or
Mutual's well Reagan health plans buying
everybody a basic health plan with a
level of subsidy based on their age and
income he's a very liberal Democrat he
has the most market-oriented there just
to show us crude of the politics are a
couple Republicans said this sounds good
I'll endorse it senator Bennett from
Utah lost is real
and a conservative in Utah because he
had the gall to come out for the most
market or anything that happened to be
supported by a Democrat now that enough
Democrats go on sale we can't do that
it's a terrible idea because it looks
too much like what some Republican might
have suggested the reality is when you
get past the rhetoric you're trying to
change behavior and health system and
the best plane out there's Ron widens
has been for a long time it can't pass
because all these institutions with
gleaming new hospitals and buildings and
bed towers have all been built up in all
these communities with too much
infrastructure that it's gonna have to
be got built up gradually the last 60
years it's going to be changed gradually
the next 60 years not gonna happen
overnight I would say that's that
illustrates the importance of thinking
about never never think about policy
without the politics so you know I fell
in love with the widened Bennett plan I
I got mushy about it a moist in the eyes
every time I thought about it and so I
would go to the White House and talk
about widen Bennett and I remembered a
hearing at the beginning of the ACA
process there were like 10 or 11 health
economists in this one Senate hearing
and they were all for it basically and
so then you go to the White House and
you'd say what about when Bennett and
they say if we were designing our health
care system from the ground up we'd be
for that too but that's not the world
we're in we're not going to get rid of
the employer duction so we're in a
different world and so the debate is
always you know fighting with the army
you got in Rumsfeld's phrase and so it's
interesting to me now to talk about some
of the reforms you talked about I
remember in the middle of the ACA fight
I went over to the OMB and was
interviewing all these health economists
about what would bend the cost curve and
and they finally said we don't know what
will work we'll just throw some stuff
out and we'll figure it out and so now a
couple years later you hear a different
argument which is we don't know what
will work let's wait and see we've
thrown something out there let's just
wait there's nothing we can do right now
let's wait four or five years and then
we'll have an argument on health care
after we've got a little more knowledge
my reaction to that would be to distrust
and verify I am a little dubious that
any of these things will work simply
because I think the fundamental
incentives are still screwed up in the
system and therefore it's interesting to
watch the debate among the people who do
want to do something now which is
essentially a debate between the
people who want to cap and the people
who want to reform and the way I see it
I don't follow it as closely as you its
Democrats tend to want to cap down the
overall spending and Republicans want to
or at least notionally want to reform
the fundamental incentive did I just say
that David I just say that it's me
reform if if you say reform is only
doing some kind of voucher with private
plans then yes I think that there is
that divide but I wouldn't I think
they're already talked about some other
reforms including carrying forward that
reforms and I also say the wait and see
view I don't think is it's fair to say
it's let's not do anything right now it
splits but let's keep pursuing the path
of reform that was a student is just
starting off which is why it's hard to
credit the ACA for this slow down right
so I mean why do you get in this debate
it unfortunately pouches peel say
vouchers I mean Jim McDermott use nice
guy ranking Democrat ways means you're
going to give my grandmother in Seattle
a ten-thousand-dollar voucher made good
by health care that's not the way it
works you basically it's the way the
Federal Employee Benefit health benefits
plan works it's the way the ACA works on
present without it not with president
president I'm saying that with with
people tom f reform Medicare with
private plans it works the same way that
the ACA does both exchanges and the same
day it does the fell employed you by the
basic plan and you get a subsidy level
based on your on your income level and
when you look at price capping look the
only major experiment members with
capping prices of Medicare I was all
over I was the White House guy in 1989
physician payments were growing fifteen
percent a year we had a Democratic House
Democratic Senate I worked for President
Bush we cut a deal with Rostenkowski and
said we're going to set a target three
percent of our inflation for inflation
growth with a target has seven percent a
year roughly and good you know professor
Xiao at Harvard designed the system will
set a relative valuables fix all the
price for the docs will put a price cap
on this with Democrats wanted we were
desperate to control spending and we
said I will go with it and we put that
price cap in and what happened since
1989 started in 1992 every time it came
up we went over the price the target was
seven we spent eleven and Congress came
back to make a tough call to ratchet
down on a Mac of the price they delayed
it so what happens this year as
here at the UH theory of a twenty-eight
percent cut for doctors which will never
happen this SGR fix that is we have one
giant experiment for now whatever it is
30 years 28 years of putting in a price
cap and a volume control and adjusting
it the way the macro economist who like
five year plans would do Paul is like
yeah it hasn't worked it's led to a
complete meltdown a physician payment
I'm kidding okay here's the rub so I
think in the current political climate
liking comedy so I think liking
competition is very very different than
disliking government and I think what
happens in health care is that you need
an architecture to make these markets
function because you need certain
regulations and and I think the folks
who are pushing very very hard for
premium support plans which I actually
think have a lot of not premium support
but probably like Medicare Advantage on
steroids I think has a lot of Merit the
challenges you can't put the
infrastructure around it right now it
would allow those markets to function
effectively so you probably can't you
know look at the exchanges defining
minimum standards and just how
aggressive that got that debate got so
there it's not the people are pushing
for competition they're just essentially
rallying against government and I think
it's important to sort of say I'm for
highly regulated competitive structure
so I think it's right just don't think
you can get that right now Sarah let me
just make one very small point so when I
say I say vouchers personal because I
think people understand what the term
means even if it has become pejorative I
think of it in the same way that you
know it's been used as a term in a whole
series of debates right which is an
alternative way of delivering public
services do you think it's a fair way to
describe the exchanges as well er yes i
do except for i will say that there is
there is a small technical distinction
between what the proposals that
sometimes go under the term premium
support and those you might call
vouchers and i do think this is
something that's it's so it's so
technical it gets lost but it's really
important to understand the fundamental
question so get past I don't believe
there's there is evidence that the
private plans have I know there's
evidence of private plans have cost more
and I don't think there's very good
evidence that we can make it so that the
private plans are going to be more
effective than Medicare and controlling
costs if we use Medicare's bargaining
power effectively but that put that
aside the issue with the with premiums
premium support windows originally
designed the idea was that the amount
that was
it would be fixed like the fe federal
employees health benefit is a share of
premiums right and so if you could get
premium costs are stopped rising you
save money if not you're paying eighty
percent or seventy percent of whatever
the premiums end up being the shift that
happened and it makes sense that it
happened because you want to get the
Congressional Budget Office to score
that you're gonna get the big savings is
we will say that we're going to pay this
amount which will and you know will be
vague about how it is but it will only
grow more than a certain amount if the
cost of health of care if health
insurance grows faster than that amount
unless you have some kind of protections
which would then vitiate the savings
you're going to be shifting more and
more costs on seniors that's just a
fundamental point and that I think is
often missed in the debate about this in
and there is a distinction there I think
it may be the great risk or a great a
great reward of the vomit approach which
is that it is actually at least aspires
to pay some fixed amount of the of the
total but ya know so if you do not have
an effective way of controlling costs
and you say where the liability of say
the federal government only grow at this
amount you will essentially be saying
more and more of those costly shift on
the seniors the first version of the
Ryan plan it was going to be massive
second version it's smaller and we
should have it we should be debating
that my view is that if you think you
can actually control thought through
Medicare as I do that's the army we have
and the army I like then we should
actually be why would we want to go down
the route of creating a lot of risk of
shifting costs particularly under
vulnerable beneficiaries for a minute
yeah go ahead I just have a
comprehensive political point which is
my observation covering politicians it's
none of this is going to happen I mean
at first I want to I don't call them
vouchers i call them pell grants for
health care i was going to say there's a
pell grant about trip
but but I know if you you know discover
the politics that I think you made
reference to it this is not a 50-50
issue there's an 8020 issue just don't
touch anything and people have you know
you go to the town hall meetings and
people have a certain set of
misconceptions one is they paid in they
get out and I paid for this why should I
get my money back the second is just
profound distrust did anything the
government's going to do which is why
Obamacare is still fundamentally
unpopular the third and this I saw on
the social security reform debate when
in the second Bush term of w bush is the
issue didn't break down Liberal Democrat
it broke down educated uneducated and
that's because certain number of unless
education in a riskier economic
situation did not want any change they
thought would increase risk levels and
how they live their lives and it didn't
matter if they were super conservative
and everything else and so when they
talked about privatizing Social Security
whatever you want to call it they were
against that even if they were really
conservative because they have enough
risk in their lives and so that these
are all comprehensive reasons why
nothing's going to happen and then there
were the final one thing I want to
mention you mentioned Danny Rostenkowski
I'm really struck by how every member of
Congress I know has a certain image
seared onto their brain and I would go
on youtube and type in Danny
Rostenkowski Town Meeting and you'll get
this news report Danny Rostenkowski goes
home to Chicago I forget what the exact
issue what catastrophic kill it was the
first drug benefit I was it it was the
middle of the only modern social policy
to be repealed before it actually took a
fact probably buddy Republicans have
been trying to create a second version
but they didn't they haven't succeeded
so you go just quickly he goes to this
town hall meeting they're angry seniors
they won't let him in the meeting
they're chasing he's running away from
them they're chasing them of the walkers
and then he gets in his car and they
surround the car and they're you know
they're just he it's completely
humiliating so no I can't outrun the
seniors well that's the Cask you mean we
don't have his far outside Haley
Rostenkowski that Rostenkowski one of
the greatest deal cutters ever never
known and he was did a lot of great
stuff people don't realize social
security was saves largely by him in san
ramon and a few other
people and the South Korea tire mage
which is now 66 not 65 was moved 25
years ago very quietly by him and nobody
notices people talk about moving the
retirement age of Medicare 65 it's 66
for Medicare nobody seems to have
noticed it's happened one punch at a
time for talk is for so security and the
point is that raza Gans did a lot of
great stuff because he had guts and the
guts is something that's sadly lacking
in both parties what I want to follow up
on that what do I know being in
Washington we always talk about we're
spending too much on Medicare I hear the
phrase tipping point all the time in my
reporting but I can't get someone to
tell me you know what says we're at a
Medicare tipping point what says we're
spending too much what do you maybe I'll
start with you since you raised the
point when does it get to a point where
legislators say we have to do something
like what do you see as a situation
where you know after they've seen this
guy get trampled by seniors on this car
when do they say like okay that's a good
idea I don't think we're close to that I
mean it's the squeeze is happening now
this is not a future problem if you're
working on child health issues if you're
working on education issues if you look
at sequestration the squeeze is
happening right now and I'm sort of
mystified by the way why the domestic
discretionary constituencies don't get
together and create a young versus old
generational warfare up front and I sort
of wish that would happen i don't think
i don't think it's it's a slow now one
thing it's always worth pointing out
this metaphor of boiling the frog that's
not actually true frogs jump out of the
water but it's nonetheless a useful
metaphor and so I think it's this
gradual problem it's very hard to see an
8020 issue being bucked by either party
the Republicans fascinate me because
notionally they support the Ryan plan
operationally I'm not sure any of them
really do except for Paul Ryan and for
other people the answer is never by the
way sadly because I can tell you in 1981
and Jandra of 19 I want to start working
for senator from Washington State named
Slade Gorton and I remember first week I
was there he walked out in the Senate
floor and said health care expenses are
six point five percent of GDP they're
totally out of control this campus is
staying forever we have to do something
about it absolutely this disaster in
disgrace we've got to fix that number
one national priority and that was six
point five percent of GDP it's now what
18 f 19 so people want to spend money on
health care and seniors are very strong
consider
but when you look at it it's not just
Medicare Medicaid is a bigger mess than
Medicare by a factor of 100 nobody ever
talks about it because Medicare is more
politically sensitive as a fiscal
disgrace there's no management to at all
those state as any idea what their match
rates are complete mess and the
disability problems are two and a half
times what they were ten years ago you
think there's two and a half times it
may disabled people as there were ten
years ago no there's just massive
political pressure to put more
discipline silly on the roles and when
you look at the budget deficit you're
collecting two point six trillion in
spending three point seven and this
isn't gonna get fixed Congress will
never have the guts to fix it what's
going to get fixed is also when interest
rates go from one and a half percent
eighteen percent where they were when I
got out of college and then you'll have
a national meltdown all the stuff out to
be fixed in a crisis which is what will
happen sadly when you have a total
disaster and ever he's going to have to
pull the plug on all these problems but
you know Medicare Medicaid this ability
Social Security to or what you're eating
up the government and you're right then
that's the fundamental problem and we're
not paying for it anyway even open up to
questions from the audience in a second
so if you have anything burning can you
yeah go ahead i want to just just to say
i think health care costs bound programs
are eating up the federal government
social security is not i mean i think if
you look so Henry Aaron a few years back
did these calculations he's a economist
of the Brookings Institution I think
they hold true if you take all the you
know the CBO projections and you just
factor out anything that's driven by
health care costs our long-term budget
picture does not look that bad I think
there are two things I just want to put
on the table here one is that if we
really value Medicare a lot then we're
going to spend more money for it and so
there's a real issue of where we get
revenues to fund the program the
original proposal that led to widen I
don't have widened Bennett had this but
the original proposal that led to it
came out of workers so you can manual
and others where they they wanted to use
a consumption tax of that to fund health
care i think there's actually real merit
in that so i put you know I so not only
do I support an enforceable budget and
Medicare I'm also publicly in favor of
consumption taxes which is why it's so
wonderful that I'm a
tenured professor politician the other
thing I would just say is I think
there's a little bit too we're being a
little too pessimistic here after all
medicare spending growth I think I said
it before it's growing at point four
percent per capita faster than our
economy I know that in the past there
have been periods in which cost
slowdowns have been followed by rapid
increases but there is some evidence I
think that we could do and Medicare's
costs have grown more slowly over time
and so I think you know there we've
spent vastly more than any other country
on health care but we do not our
citizens do not show vastly better
health outcomes we do not visit the
doctor more often we do not we do not
see evidence for in these numbers that
we're spending more days in the hospital
there is certainly more intensity in
American healthcare but there is a lot
of evidence that we could save money let
me just give you like two simple
examples right there pretty obvious the
way that we buy you know medical devices
is completely broken and we could spend
vastly less if we did much more
competitive bidding for medical devices
to drug drug costs have fallen in part
because of the increased use of generics
there are ways in which we could
accelerate the slow down and drug costs
that I think would be quite effective it
is notable that Medicare does not have
the tools to control drug costs that
Medicare or the VA do and here again you
could say if you could slow the rate of
increase quite substantially so i guess
i'm ultimately think if we value
medicare as I think we should that we
can't afford it if we make a much more
serious effort to control costs and if
we identify revenues because over time
we are going to have more people in the
program so even if we control per capita
class we're going to have to figure out
ways to finance it in case as Tommy you
know if we had two big balls sort of the
the Ryan wide and you know dream changes
that are structural what are some small
ball yeah things that you would do
tomorrow you know look a lot of things
are changing I things change slowly in
health care I've been doing this for a
long time sadly and you know nothing
changes quickly but look when i got to
CMS we had three percent of people of
Medicare Advantage now 28 and a half
percent i can tell you i won't switch to
the details but the reason Medicare
Advantage plans were overpaid their
price has been coming down the main
reason prices are dropping his relatives
to get paid less and they're very good
when they get squeezed and cutting costs
well you know you know the move day cos
I say is a better than a sharp stick in
the eye it's okay it's like netted
Medicare beige light it's better than
nothing giving doctors risk the more you
can get the risk out of the trust funds
and the government and into some
third-party capitalists well regulate
hands the better performance is going to
be and I credit the administration for
doing that acos is a marginal move in
the right direction more people in
Medicare removes the edge is a marginal
move in the right direction post-acute
bundling which therefore an acute
bundling is a move in the right
direction all these things to move more
bundled risk into third party payer or
marginally good and they're all helping
a little bit so I think you know a lot
of things to give them credit from you
in the right direction the big picture
change is really mine just fundamental
difference of opinion do you want to
control costs by the government control
costs or you want to regulate markets
and try to fix some of these screwed-up
things we have in the market to
basically create you know a well
regulated market of competition to
control costs I tend to go on the more
well regulated competitive side but you
know there's a lot going on that are
marginally getting better I mean to say
something like the biggest tax exclusion
there is right now for
employer-sponsored health insurer I've
been a fan for a tax cap for 30 there's
absolutely no reason for those you to
understand i'm a partner in a private
equity firm in New York every penny I
pay and my kids for health care for
braces for eyeglasses for anything is
you know why not we just pay it out of
the pot it's it's a tax expenditure why
would I get taxed on that money so I
could spend thirty five thousand dollars
a year in health care my firm pays for
it you know the PO the right policy
which senator Baucus was foreign got
pounded by the unions yep he's a
Democrat and many Democrats are for
including widen is to say look everybody
is entitled to a Blue Cross standard
option health care plan if that's twelve
thousand bucks a year great that's tax
exempt you can get that pre-tax any more
than that you're gonna get taxed on it's
totally the right policy bipartisan
groups from Democrats Republicans report
who was against it in my opinion
short-sighted the union's killed it in
the president's reform plan the
president's for it
by the way because unions tend of
negotiate over the years whether you're
the communications workers river for
very plush benefits packages and they
were afraid that they get their health
care benefits cut and we can get it back
in cash number one bipartisan ran study
every kind of ever met number one thing
you should do is cap the exclusion of
taxes limit it take that money and put
it back in the pot for other people
there's no debate about that it's all
politics also a great way to kill your
political career it is but there are
plenty of Democrats and Republicans were
out there for it the problem is is it
play out as a trade-off and I look I
understand the administration went
through a great negotiation get this
bill done I don't agree at all but they
deserve great credit is a democratic
priority for 50 years they got done with
nobody else good and they trip it played
a lot of trade-offs and one of them was
they didn't want to make the union's man
so it was called a Cadillac the little
teeny sliver of it that they had left in
the bill was called the Cadillac tax it
should have been a lot bigger it should
have been with funded a lot more of the
program and it's totally the right thing
to do you want to see you there any
questions from the audience I'm anyone
want to put to make our panelists yeah I
guess we have like a billion microphones
of the outsides of their room and if we
can make the the questions questions
yeah uh yes it looked good introduce
yourself and questions right instead of
comments after okay Jacob hi I'm bill
sage I'm visiting the law school from
University of Texas so if you read the
table of contents of the Affordable Care
Act it's got ten titles the first two
about health insurance the third about
the delivery of healthcare services but
number four is about health keeping us
healthier and if we don't do that we're
broke as surely as if we don't get
health care delivery cheaper you haven't
said a word about health that's
equipment yeah and what are we gonna do
about that yes a question exactly what
are we going to say thank you Bill but
it's a part of Jody sin lar is here is
the sort of smoking guru a any partners
we talk about the revenue shortfalls why
not introduce sin taxes you know so that
I think it's a hundred billion over ten
years if you raise the tax on
echo alcohol and sugared beverages make
Mike Bloomberg present for you yeah
nobody just ban him we need a tax
revenue I would be for it I mean I would
say one thing that fits in but David set
up front is that a lot of the things
that you do to improve health would not
would not involve health insurance as
much as I believe strongly that the
basic financial security offered by
health insurance and the access to
high-quality care provided by insurance
is crucial there are also a lot of other
vital things that we could be doing to
improve health that we need funds to do
so these two things are not not not
separate within within you know Medicare
properly I think that that a lot of the
the incentives for for excessive amounts
of high-tech specialty care I think are
if not if not sometimes iatrogenic that
is reducing health but are they at the
very least very low yield for spending
kinds of interventions and so I'm happy
that the Affordable Care Act did some
things on the preventive front and I
think we should be doing a lot more
there but I think a lot of the changes
that are needed are also be on the
health health insurances yeah I would
have one of the bigger commitments the
Affordable Care Act made to improving
health with the Sun ten-million-dollar
public health and prevention fund which
has if you're democrat it's you know
great investment if some republican
senators have criticized it as a slush
fund for jungle gems which democrats
will say you know we're fine with it
being a slush fund virgin jungle jims we
think that will actually improve
community health one of the things i did
a long series on that program last year
and one of the things that struck me is
a real challenge is those programs
usually don't pay dividends for decades
so it's kind of a challenge in
Washington where you're trying to create
some immediate savings but you're trying
to also invest in programs that won't
pay off you know within a CBO budget
window so there's real tension between
you know these longer term investments
and health and you've already seen that
now in Washington that fund has been cut
back twice i think it's about seven
billion dollars right now so it's really
it's been a very easy target because
is it's you know much more long-term
program it's kind of a silly debate you
think about the agency CMS spends a
trillion-dollar on Medicare and Medicaid
and that's a 10 billion dollar fund
there were ten years I mean it's a joke
it's I would you know I ran CMS we had a
demo budget to demonstrate these things
of 80 million years 70 million which is
earmarked by Senator Arkham another son
you couldn't do anything so there's
nothing this this little demo fun to try
new ideas is a harmless if we
Republicans talking about silly the
issue is much much bigger policy the
real issue which you look at it and I'm
not a big critic of the ACA structurally
I'm a big critic of the spending
sixty-two percent of americans are going
to get subsidized health care that's
insane four hundred percent of poverty
is ninety four thousand four dollars for
a family of four which is not a lot in
new haven connecticut it's not a lot in
washington DC it's a hell of a lot in
kansas and nebraska and when you get to
the point where 6th where 400 scent of
poverty sixty-two percent of americans
can get subsidized health care the
wheels have come off and that you know
this is the structure is right that
amount of spending that isn't this thing
is absolutely completely whacked out I
mean I think there's there's some
interesting work look at the
relationship doing how much we spend as
a country in the outcomes we get and
inevitably you find that the countries
that spend less get more I think it's
easy to sort of in for a causation I
don't think it's there the interesting
parts this countries that spend very
little on health care spend a whole lot
more in the welfare state and the sort
of ancillary services around it to help
for the poor housing early childhood
education and so I think it's it's
getting over this fallacy that the
health care or health care spending is
exclusively the driver of Health and I
don't know when there's something I mean
I sitting here certainly what I many
things about being CMS administrator
should try for viewers you get to get
every crappy town America and see their
hospitals i can tell you you go any
place in the west and i've been in
virtually every county and every state
at some point and there's boarded up
shopping centers and board up everything
I Karen t they have a brand new hospital
of brand new wing that's a supporting
the economy if you look at the economy
of central if I don't pick on a state
iowa which I've been to a lot of where
Kansas or Nebraska pick any state
Medicare look on the say it's wrong but
the economy is social security checks
and medic here through the hospital and
the rest of these towns make cases on
let's say it's good or bad but the fact
is the social policy is wild but there's
this element of tragedy here we're all
saying there's a huge problem is
nothing's going to happen you know and
and you know first of all we know
they'll come to my life but there's
gotta be so is it worth creating a
federal reserve for health care you know
you're sitting here watching a train
wreck you know you just have to be going
very slowly as you approach the the wall
well that yeah optimistic know it over
switch over next week this is a small
ball question for professor Cooper mr.
Scully has been through one of these
cycles before where hospitals acquired
independent physician practices and it
didn't work out very well the past 10
years we've given hospitals more money
site of service differentials the
various add-ons that come with teaching
programs so-called provider-based
reimbursement which they can use to now
acquire physician practices once again
past 10 years round numbers we have one
at a thousand more practitioners and one
hundred thousand fewer independent
practitioners does anybody care that we
seem to be buying the same service at
two or three times the price and that
that is our official government
price-fixing administered price policy
is that something which we can possibly
look at so that when the Medicare
beneficiary goes to find a doctor they
won't be necessarily going into an
institution so I think it's an
incredible point I think it's something
that was raised in simpson-bowles
basically the chemotherapy is a great
example you get a different rate if you
have it locally at a doctor's office
versus going to a hospital and getting
it and right now with hospitals have
discovered as if you buy up the local
clinics you can get twice as much for
the same thing so I think pay parity is
incredibly important it's in
simpson-bowles I think it's something
they should do tomorrow I think the
issue is talking about just to me that I
may be the only ones in the weeds of
this but you know the problem is seven
years ago thirty five percent of
physicians of the country were working
for hospitals now it's sixty percent the
part of this is just the consolidation
fear most docs or selling the practice
the hospital's part of the other thing
those if you were a doc cross the street
from Yale hospital and you had
independent practice and you got paid a
hundred bucks to see a patient the
second you sell the hospital y el
hospital you get paid hundred thirty
percent because you're hospital-based
reimbursement is the same patient same
thing just change the sign on the door
that's why a lot of these got docs are
shelling it's true driving crazy
behavior we happened on half the
hospitals in Albuquerque so so I'm just
make it's my interest but when you look
at it when the hospital is done
everything and I love hospitals I used
to run a big gospel Association what do
they do it'll keep you a lot of
hospitals they fill them up when the
docs work for hospital the incentive to
fill the bed is not empty so independent
docs are a much better thing in the
policy I think unintentionally and
innocently has driven docs to sell their
practices the hospital's this massive
consolidation last five years six years
it's incredibly unhealthy for the health
care system very dangerous and you're
totally right I don't think he'll to
talk about enough requested over there
hi yeah I wanted to pick up on the
health issue again we've had this
conversation sort of as though
everybody's health status is exogenous
but we know that a lot of the costs
associated with Medicare have to do with
chronic conditions that people can to a
certain extent prevent by lifestyle
choices and there's reason to think that
there's aspects of benefit design that
could actually affect those choices so
sometimes i wonder if there's sort of a
disconnect when people spend most of
their life you know having employee
insurance and having a certain carrier
then they retire switch carriers and
medicare sort of inherits the problems
of old age that the prior carrier didn't
really have any incentive to prevent
that much so sometimes I wonder could we
reduce Medicare costs by preventing more
illness if we had more of sort of a
situation where everybody was in the non
group market and we had a more sort of
privatized version of Medicare and
people could retain the same carrier
from their earlier working years through
their older years older years I agree
you know you see united healthcare which
is a large share of the advantage
program you know why could we figure out
a loop around so they could essentially
capture somebody from before the
challenge there's what happens if they
start skimping on quality you know so
essentially what you think about is the
analog to cell phones you know i can buy
a three year plan that's a whole lot
cheaper than buying minutes each time i
need to use it the question is what
happens if the quality of the service
goes down and so I don't know we've got
in the contract what happens when your
length in the contract
and how you maintain quality during that
period but I think it's absolutely right
I think she gets more questions my name
is Billy listen I'm a research scientist
I work on fruit flies which makes me the
doctor in the family my mother passed
away at 87 last year and she was on
Medicare one of the things that has
struck me about your discussion it's
very wonky but when you think about
health care and about the actual effects
on people and what they're choosing I
wonder if you're not missing the forest
for the trees and the reason I say that
is when you're sick whether you're old
or young you're not making you know
there are emotional issues you may be
demented as my mother was unable to make
really sensible rational choices in a
marketplace so on that score I kind of
think that you have to be careful about
how you structure things thinking that
people are going to go out and
understand what care is best for them my
mother thought the doctors knew what was
best for her she relied on them and they
said to go do this or go do that I was
representative for her on the other
thing I would say that I am a little
skeptical my mother grew up in a
generation that believed that doctors
were there to take care of people and
all the discussion now is markets and
money and setting it up so the right
incentives are there so that we can pay
people to be doing this and I think that
that's a fundamental change in the
social contract that by saying what we
should be doing is having money be the
rule rather than having people taking
care of other people that that causes a
big
thing are you do you want to I can take
on the more human element of Medicare
reform well I just say look when you I
mean realistically I totally understand
what you're saying but the reality is
it's just a fact of life you know I
think the health care professions filled
with the most honorable wonderful people
I know and I've been doing it for 35
years it's the money drives behavior so
when you look at you know my mom was in
the hospital when I was running seeing
us for five and a half months without
Steve myelitis went through six
hospitals because of the way the thief
shares just worked no doc you know her
brother was the chief staff of the
hospital Doc's came through because they
get paid seeing the patient every
specialist in Philadelphia came through
and check the box sar nobody is
responsible for her care they weren't
bad guys they're trying to the right
thing but they're all being squeezed by
various payment systems and you know the
anesthesiologist and surgeon and every
other guy comes by and and they just
they it's you know drive through
medicine then I'll try and do the right
thing but they follow the incentives
that system creates hospitals or
wonderful places they follow instead of
the systems crates so I think if you're
trying to be here for your mom or my mom
or else you want a system that creates
the right incentives for these people
who are really trying to the right thing
to follow the flow and I happen to
believe that when somebody's at risk for
taking care of your mom for a year or
three years or whatever and they look at
it the whole package they're going to
worry more about preventative care in
the whole system because their moneys at
risk and there's nothing unhealthy about
that's just the way the system works the
problem right now is nobody's
responsible for anything everybody comes
through every dock every hospital checks
the box maximally reimbursement and
they're not trying to be evil or bad
it's just the way the system is set up
and as a result of that no one's
responsible well I would just add to
that that I think one does not have this
to have a kind of mutually exclusive
view where the incentives matter but
professionalism and norms professional
norms or expertise don't matter because
the the idea that I think here with Tom
and I agree that it's if you set up you
want to set up the incentives properly
it allows physicians to have clinical
economy in the right ways and the right
kinds of support systems to allow them
to deliver care effectively in ways that
are integrated across different
providers and so on and I would only
just say here that I think they're too
kind of sleeper issues here that matter
a lot for health care costs and that we
don't that you know have kind of gotten
off the radar screen one is liability
and
practice I think this is a it's it's a
mistake the way it's broken down and I'm
purely partisan lines because the system
just doesn't work very well and it is
shaping the way in which doctors
interact with patients and it's shaping
I don't think it has a huge effect on
our health crafts but I think it does
shape the way the system plays out the
other is there's a lot of conflicts of
interest in our system visit with
physicians and other providers and you
know this self referral to to medical
equipment the fact that there's just
rampant forms a kind of pharmaceutical
marketing that take place I just think
that that again you people will respond
to those incentives right if we really
want people to prescribe like look cost
generic drugs and it's probably not the
greatest thing that every medical school
if you talk to those people everything
gets paid for in continuing medical
education a ton of this stuff is getting
paid for by private companies that want
to get people to prescribe expensive
stuff so I think I think we should have
that kind of larger dialogue just one
other quick issue as you were speaking I
was reminded of a piece Daniel Callahan
and chef Mullen wrote a republic on
end-of-life issues and their point I
hear very very things I don't know the
answer this how big a cost factor
end-of-life issues actually are in this
problem you hear diverse things on that
but their main point was that our
inability to think about the finitude of
life makes us take heroic measures and I
would say from my experience when I
wrote up their article the feedback I
got was it's rarely the person who's
sick who wants to take the most heroic
inexpensive measures it's the family at
the end who wants to do those things and
the other thing I got a lot of feedback
was but if you give that family skin in
the game and make them pay the costs
that suddenly they don't want to take
the heroic measures so I guess that we
love mom and dad that's my cousin bucks
so but I think do take those end-of-life
issues are immoral more than that play
into the incident how you doing I'm Andy
Carano a retired psychologist once I
retired about a year ago I spent more
time and doctor
than all of my 35 years work so in five
years I'll have Medicare and your
frankly scaring me but you know a great
question by the way and a great question
by the other folks I don't want to pile
on here but you know David I heard you
speak a while back here and I think you
made a mention of Geoffrey Canada in in
New York and you made the point that
there's no cause and effect relationship
between one variable and another and
that you got to throw everything at it
what else are we not looking at are we
not looking at the elderly's behavior
you made a comment about people living
down in Naples playing golf well I know
a lot of teachers that move down there
they sold their houses they worked hard
they went down there to be healthy
because he cures and golf keeps them
keeps them healthy so it's not just rich
people living down there it's people
that want to stay healthy do we know
anything about elderly behavior I see
people who refuse operations get better
they make good decisions they're not
raping the system as much but do we have
any solid evidence that you know people
are doing good things and making good
decisions do we have anything on that
could I just do a quick thing on just a
general principle of how to deal with
really complicated terrible issues like
this one or like education so there's a
guy in University of Virginia named Turk
imer who studies the relationship
between poverty and IQ and he finds that
people who raised in poverty have lower
IQs because of economic stress bad
nutrition a whole bunch of reasons and
they tried to figure out which variable
contributes lower IQ and he did a whole
you know decades of studies trying to
figure out which variable explains lower
IQ and he found he couldn't it's not any
one variable it's the intermarriage of a
zillion different variables and so how
do you deal with a problem like that he
calls it the gloomy prospect you can't
see down into that problem it's too
complicated and so to me when you have a
gloomy prospect sort of problem which is
healthcare rising costs are a gloomy
prospect sort of problem you flood the
zone you try everything all at once and
hope that you somehow mysteriously
generate a positive feedback loop to
counteract the negative feedback loop
and so the Harlem Children's Zone which
Geoffrey Canada runs in New York is an
example of that we don't know what
causes power
what causes kids to drop out of school
so we'll try everything all at once
within the geographic area and hope
something works or you get a feedback
mechanism and that seems to be a
sensible way to think about complex
problems over here in this case that's a
there's going to be an inappropriate
question but the topic of a liability
came up when you ask physicians about
health care costs is often one of the
main points that kind of comes up and is
very aggressively discussed just a
question about the policy and the
politics of liability possible
arbitration medical expert panels and
minikin states start by saying you know
within the economic literature they
found basically know if that of
malpractice on rising health care
spending I mean it doesn't mean it
doesn't exist but there's not been any
other not shown it no i mean i'll send
you one hundred studies no I mean I so I
think it's important but I don't think
we we know definitively that that's look
at Cal I mean I I think jack is
accurately summarizing the canonical a
disguise so no is shown small too small
to non-existent effect right now in
other websites what do you do so I think
with safe harbors or a really good idea
so if you follow clinical guidelines you
don't get sued and so I think change is
like that matter but I think it's easy
to overstate the importance the most
liberal state in the country arguably is
California the tightest math practice
law in Oregon right not die certainly
close as California certainly the
largest state they've have made
significant malpractice reforms and caps
in california since 1972 has not caused
any great economic damage their costs in
california grown much lower general in
the rest of the country now you can
argue this low of a lower base but if
you ask docs in California they think
it's a much better system so the
arguments political it's never gonna
happen I've been fighting this fight for
35 years to but if you had by the way
they're a bunch of senators the
Republicans that are old trawlers
physicians and hospitals don't care
about this that much they care about it
but it's one of 25 other issues I know
what's your specialty is but I guarantee
if you go to the College of
anesthesiology or the gastroenterologist
still say I care about my practice form
after the other
reimbursement issues travelers care
about this and only this they raised a
lot of money to give it Democrats
Republicans it's not a close call it
will never happen it's wonderful
politics travelers are mean and tough
and they have a lot of money politicians
it's a fact it's a sad fact of life that
don't tell me if you go to California
and ask any doc in California any HTML
California anybody in California micra
has kept costs down and California's
should be the model for healthcare
nesbitt entry but I think something
simple like safe harbor reforms is
something that very few people could
disagree about I have no problem with
any of it I'd for all of my practicing
forums saying the reality is it's a pure
raw political issue travelers make money
I malpractice suits and it ain't no good
yeah I want to i put in the two yeah
let's do that sir they're left over here
so go ahead uh hi I'm Tim I'm a grad
student here Yale and I'm really
interested in the politics of death
panels and cost-effectiveness analysis
and so I guess my understanding and this
might not be quite right is that right
now Medicare can't deny coverage for
something good purely on the basis of
cost is an expensive drug or expensive
procedure as long as it's shown to be
clinically effective in some in some way
you can't deny coverage for it so I
guess my question is a do you think
that's one of these things that's going
to have to change down the road as we
talk about these very scary numbers and
be like or or be are the politics just
too blood-curdling for that to happen
let me speak to that really quickly and
I Zach may have a somewhat different
perspective since he's very close to
what's happened in the UK with nice
which is the national institute for
throwing me under the the death panel
bus here yeah I mean he also told me
personally that he think he loves dead
or when all right here and I'm just
trying to create a diversion for David
Brooks so so let's just remember what
the death penalty babe was about it was
about it wasn't about cost effective
research initially actually it was about
a provision that said that you could fit
that would support counseling for about
an end-of-life care so and then it moved
over to comparative effectiveness
research and they found Zeke Emanuel who
besides being Rahm Emanuel brother seems
like a pretty mild mannered guy but
turned into like dr. death and
medicare has a statutory restriction
from considering costs and it's worth
noting that the ipad has an additional
restriction on it which they can't
change reduce benefits while trying to
control costs so we're not anywhere near
that my own view is that that there
should be move in the direction of
thinking about the cost effectiveness of
interventions but but that but that
there there is a there is a kind of
tricky issue here which is that first of
all all these decisions get are usually
treated as incremental that is we
grandfather and everything we're doing
today I think that's a really big issue
and we're thinking a bit about so it
might be more effective rather than you
know turning some independent agency
into like the arbiter of what of what
Medicare should cover whether it's cost
effective or not which is a really big
step right now what Medicare does is
kind of backdoor ways of doing this
where it's only for certain conditions
or certain populations which turns out
to have the effect of reducing the cost
of very costly treatment and this is
going to explode with personalized
medicine it's going to explode with some
of the really high cost drugs on the
market but but we also I actually think
that one way to think about this would
be to actually do retro actively think
about differential cost sharing with
protections for for low income and very
ill patients four-tiered based on the
comparator on the effectiveness of met
so you could say for example that as we
do with drugs generic drugs right that
you have a lower cost sharing
requirement than if you go for some
really fancy brand-name drug but
actually have it informed by some
knowledge about what the comparative
quality of those is so I could just see
night nightmarish scenarios I mean
already we have a rule that stuff has to
be approved it's an FDA rule there's no
cost the fact that it's in Medicare that
has to approve and and and I'm sure time
Tom can tell us about how fraught that
process is but my own view is that it
might be more useful to think a little
bit about okay globally rather than
incrementally with each new advanced
what are the best ways that we could
encourage people to use more
cost-effective
methods its I think we've one question
left in about two or three minutes so
why don't we get to this and I think we
should all be up here or afterwards if
anyone just to follow up on that go
ahead hi my name is your mana i'm
actually a student Master Cooper's class
so I truly believe that we do need a
structure in place to bring down the
cost of health care because it's rising
astronomically but however there is a
concern of revenue loss due to different
premiums going up we're going to be
paying higher taxes and also an
increased number of enrollees for
Medicare and Medicaid and then there's a
problem health exchanges because their
states that want to do it there's other
states that don't federally we might
have to get involved and then we have to
pay costs there so my question is I'm
really like apprehensive and scared
about the future of our country because
we're already taking up seventeen
percent of the gdp so congressionally
politically we have this division
between the Republicans and Democrats
and I think Thomas Kelly said that
there's really no substance to it they
just take sites what can we do so in
three or four years after january2014
and a lot of this is implemented our
country isn't in a huge amount of debt
and deficit because or we're already at
11 trillion dollars in debt is there
anything not gonna happen in three or
four years I could say housing prices
are cheap in Canada that help you know
the realities to me I'm a mush I'm a
moderate despite the perception here you
know the reality is that there aren't
many moderates left in Congress sadly
and even the Liberals you know I have
this very friendly with Senator Kennedy
you I didn't agree with any but he was
great to work with and easy to work with
he actually believed in doing stuff on a
bipartisan basis Medicare Part D never
would have passed he supported when I
was going through the Senate sailors in
the past so just getting back to the
culture in Washington where people can
work together now if you're Republican
you work with Democrats your evil and
vice versa which is set so you know
wherever you live whether it's you know
supporting the Bob workers of the
Republican Party is a moderate senator
from Tennessee or mark Warner's in the
Democratic Party and supporting people
like that and making it okay that work
things out and find a middle ground
again because you know Democrats aren't
going to get everything done and neither
Republicans I mean it's very rare to get
one little weak in time
well they like the benefit or not where
president obama could push through that
bill and get 60 votes in the Senate
that's never happened in my lifetime
probably happen again you get divided
government and the only way to get stuff
done is to bipartisan people working
together and you increasingly got a
liberal democratic northeast and a
conservative Republican South and
Midwest and it's like two different
countries and it's a sad thing so I'd
another one thing you do is encourage
moderates to be moderate and actually
talk to each other because otherwise
you're I'm getting too old to worry
about but you're stuck I would just
quickly say that is putting the cart
before the horse you can't create a
culture of cooperation and then solve
problems you solve problems and then
create a culture of cooperation and so
I'd say the thing that needs to be done
is you have to change the debate right
now we have a debate which is the
traditional big government for a small
government debate it's vouchers versus
state control and we all know how that
debate shapes out an issue after issue
it's a 50-50 debate and so to me you
have to change the debate from be
government versus small government to
present versus future and Medicare is
present consumption and so the emphasis
should be what can we do to increase
future investment and decrease present
consumption and then try to get a series
of policies that confuse the two issues
and break out of the orthodoxies and
that we have to the administration to do
that politically I understand its
ruinous they as soon as they talk about
Medicare reforms of any sort they get
this spider sense tingling the
Democratic base is going to go crazy and
the Republicans as I say are notionally
in favor of these reforms I really don't
think they deep in their heart believe
in them but I do think it takes
leadership to change the nature of the
debate without that we are stuck in the
same old world war one yeah I would
agree i think it's small steps you know
combining the deductible that get people
to agree and then move forward the
second is i think you know the big
reforms which i think you and i don't
disagree about terribly big changes in
medicare i think we're going to have to
get passed by Democrats I think they're
the only ones who finally have the
public trust on the issue and so I think
at the end of the day the balls in their
Court and so I think we do have a four
year window the Democrats inside look we
get trust us on it it's a big issue
let's move forward with it because I
just don't think I don't think the
Republican brand can make this reform
can do it credibly and can ever get
support to make it happen yeah I would
also just add you know let's not let's
not end on too dark of a note here you
know I've just had a huge suck on the
student this is actually Zach student
those nasty so yeah and and i want to i
want to offer a couple notes of
reassurance i mean one is to say uh i
mean we are talking about again some
very serious challenges but where
there's there has been some movement
forward I mean we were five years ago
contemplating no action to help the
uninsured to try to do something
effective to deal with health care costs
and we're moving in the right direction
broadly speaking I with David I think
part of it is thinking about how can we
have a discussion that is about the
longer term challenges we face both
economic and in this both eat with
economic policy and health policy and it
is true that sort of we've seen a
falling away of kind of the moderate
impulse I think that and I've had I
thought about that a lot is a political
scientist it seems to me that the best
the three most important things we can
do in that context is I do think we need
to make our political system ultimately
more majoritarian and this cuts against
the grain of a lot of thinking because
it means that we have to accept that
sometimes we're going to be on the
losing end of majority fights but having
essentially a 60-vote threshold on every
major issue except for the budget in the
Senate is a very very big hindrance to
effectively addressing national problems
we need greater engagement the mobilized
citizens on some of these issues and
this is going to happen a lot at the
state level in the health care so it's
actually a chance to get involved and
finally I go back to this view that I do
think that for some of these fundamental
decisions they do have to be put on if
not autopilot at least on glide paths
that can be changed by politicians down
the road did there I do not I have the
same reservations that many if you do
about the ability of Congress to
micromanage every
aspect of Medicare say getting the large
priorities right creating institutions
both public and private that have
incentives to perform well over time is
is in health care where the market alone
is not going to do it is what's
essential well no more optimistic no I
think we'll bring it to a close I think
our panelist is our round of applause
for very spirited debate if you all have
anything during questions we're here and
happy to answer them and thank you for
coming thank you very much